hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play MS story
now we were running away from a moose
man or a grunt I don't know which one
think of it we lost him in this
conveniently placed room with dead
bodies can I jump off here please
ah come on come on anyway I know there's
something underneath the stairs here let
me let me down oh oh oh oh okay no I
don't feel like breaking the game it
doesn't the word Tory after going
through that prison I didn't think I
could take any more darkness if things
didn't start to look up soon I feared I
would lose my sanity forever how can
they look up your father whoa
not was up not what I was expecting um
this is some lab impressive I don't
think I've anything ever seen
architecture like that in this game very
cool
must be some clever use of something
around there either way I like it
well not so much decorations could use
some change but it's like damn the box
thank you
at least it's a bit brighter this is
actually good because I was hoping that
this custom story was gonna be a bit
more involved
locked I bet this key for this somewhere
down here I bet I just bet oh boy what
do I sound like Mickey Mouse more than
anyone else Dan the box was this note
25th of September 1840 its pyramids on
specimen continue to yield promising
results I have these test subjects know
how much good they are doing for the
entire human race sometimes a few must
suffer to benefit the masses but the
most exciting piece of news yet is what
a trusted colleague has revealed to me
today the Europe of power once thought
is a hug hoax has been proven to
actually exist I can barely contain my
excitement as I write this as soon as
possible
I shall assemble a small team to attempt
to retrieve this object if it is true
what they say about it it should bestow
the owner with the means to achieve
whatever he desires if obtained whose
use this orbit in the name of
progressive science for the betterment
of the human race nope I don't think you
did that daddy how could you daddy how
could you
now russet storage key and a large oil
potion
under firing rod a four phase amplitude
rod ah - this t anything in the fire and
this looks downright cozy death of
august 1835 today
braxton the crew and i finished
installing the new elevator since its
brand new I don't see if or see it
breaking down anytime soon
haha in case it does repairs can be made
in the machine room if the elevator
blows a rod the equipment storage
contains extra guiding rods for the
machine as well as extra cogs since
those rods are quite expensive I'll be
sure to keep an extra one here just in
case in any event the manufacturer
guarantees no breakdowns for at least a
decade so let's hope I don't have to
make any repairs for a while and I keep
the key to the equipment storage in this
room at all times to prevent theft of
machine parts from who who else is
helping
I'm curious I mean I imagine once you
know he actually had the lab oh yeah did
say that a bunch of workers were thrown
down with him I know this case piggie
yeah I won't release my mad scientist
Wow
not so cool less cool here no even less
more coolness that's cool so you went
from a pig to a pile of bones to a dead
guy and a date monster guy torture cells
do I want to go down there first nope
glass jar thank you
17th of February 18 42 I would like to
address the recent prisoner escape from
the torture cells how could you let this
happen I don't think I ever hope to
remind anyone what would happen if one
of our prisoners escaped to the surface
what we do down here is our business the
world needn't concern itself with us all
they care about is the final result
anyway so with that being said let's all
try a little bit harder to make sure no
one leaves
unfortunately coinciding with the escape
several of our elevator machine parts
have gone missing including a few
guiding rods very expensive guiding rods
let's try to avoid this happening again
so we can resume a productive line of
experiments Robert all righty then very
strict box
we're good
- the torture cells thank god the lab
was well lit I left felt strangely at
ease in there rejoicing ended
prematurely I realized that nothing
worked out ah this is more like it
yep yep this is more like correctly
picked up ah I was wondering when things
were gonna get a bit more freaky but I
am glad that there's a lot more to
Emma's story than I thought there was
gonna be oh no not the bull again oh god
I hate the ball bull was like the worst
way I could possibly think to die I'm so
with the lightboard
today I finished creating the brazen
bull for Robert this is certainly my
masterpiece
however when I opened it to show him he
pushed me inside locked the hatch and
ignited the fires below i cook slowly
suffocating for an hour before I died
he'd cuz I'm a ghost
cool why was I supposed to light that
fire not sure
and the tinderbox is right there what oh
my I'm in double high in the MU is
mandible why is there a woman laughing
oh I'm roasting alive
I guess my goose is cooked
how did I get in the bull yep that's me
roasting alive yep she's going crazy
emma is going crazy I feel like hello
Thank You mistress apart deliver guy
woman lady I'm curious is why there is a
woman laughing maniacally when bad stuff
happens
oh no no you can't make me
oh no no no that would no no no you
can't make me go in there that was like
ten times worse than the scary music
that normally goes on oh look the Iron
Maiden being trapped down here offers
his purse I overheard Robert talking
about some kind of guiding machine Ron
that is vital to the function of the
elevator I knew what I had to do when
the time was right I managed to escape
captivity for just long enough to run to
the machine room and steal a rod I have
hidden it somewhere down here in the
torture area somewhere
he will least expect it but this is only
part of my revenge
I must have patient Alexandria Dante's
jump-scare never have I seen or
experienced something more horrible than
the Iron Maiden was locked inside
unfortunately no room to move by
accidentally if I accidently shuddered
or twitched one of the spikes would
impale me not deep enough to kill me of
course but the resulting pain would
cause me to inadvertently move again
thus continuing the process until I
eventually died on blood loss
and let me guess turn it d-did dick oh
oh no oh no oh no oh oh yeah oh oh oh
this is not a good view oh oh thank you
Audrey oh boy thank you
I must have hurt really badly not me I
am professional European weightlifter
lady but I am very feminine I know I
know that bad stuff in here
yeah weird things you don't know about
half of it this guy won't open up I bet
he has the key in there too could there
be ways to compromise the lock how about
this nope oh I need the drill I bet I
need the drill I feel like a gun with my
massive muscles
I am so strong I am so strong with my
massive muscles I will crush your head
like a gold nut what's this one what's
the torture gonna be this time
what's behind door oh this is phenomenal
and let me guess
am I gonna go in it I'm gonna go down it
for having mercy on any test subject
Robert punished me by tying me upside
down by the feet to the wooden rack to
his mindless servants proceeded to saw
me in half vertically until the saw
caught in my Bella's bone because I was
upside down the blood rushed to my head
and it took longer for me to bleed to
death not fun here we go yep here we go
I am upside down
oh goodness what people watching oh my
okay I changed my mind
that's Thor's way oh god I can't even
imagine that I can't even imagine that
oh man that would be like that ten
billion times the worst way to go right
up your yeah and then it comes lodged in
your pelvis bone oh no oh no oh no yeah
oh God oh it's not happy fun times for
no one I'm coming in better get you
ready for keys key to it oh no I'm like
you can keep the frigging key good god
oh oh no oh no oh no no no not this
[Music]
let's give it to me and let me get out
of here give me and let me go just give
it to me let me go where's the free
turkey feathers January 1844 and it's
been over a month now since my last
century this or gives me more power than
I could've possibly imagined why did I
ever think to use it for good I can
literally copy anything now I shall
increase my torturing now for scientific
reasons but because it is so much fun
watching people scream and beg pathetic
I have never I've come up with a plan
involving Emma and her suitor Neil she
is smart but she will never expect
I must make the preparations soon I will
become a mortal Robert all right you do
that
Robert Papa daddy oh there's no key in
here is it there's no key
there is no key is there there's no key
there is no key there's no key give me a
give me up
give me a oh okay all right that's all
the time I got for this episode thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos of stuff that
I've done and as always I will see you
in Nice video